zoix like scoob like we're in a mediocre
movie
you know in this quarantine i see this
comment in the comment section like whoa
we're scraping the bottom of the barrel
a lot of times i'm like no
these are movies i want to talk about i
get to choose what i talk about now but
now scoob's out and it's a new movie and
although it's a new movie yes i do feel
like we are scraping the bottom of some
barrel
so here we go i'm not dressing up for
this one though i don't even have a
coffee mug none of that no i'm just
just not dressing up i'm going to show
them the care they showed me when they
made this movie which is not much at all
so this is
let's just do it and have some fun while
we do i'm here for you in these trying
times
[Music]
scoob that's the last time i'll do the
voice maybe so scoob is a new animated
scooby-doo movie when you say animated
these days
of course it means cgi for the most part
and this is the most
2020 scooby-doo movie that could have
ever
scooby-doo'd today like i would have
been fine with the whole you know the
mystery and they're in the haunted house
and they unmasked the ghost you know
basic scooby-doo stuff and when it
starts out it actually starts out like
that there's a big haunted house in the
neighborhood and they go in there and
there's this ghost i was like oh cool
all right scooby-doo stuff let's uh and
then that's over with then they team up
with captain falcon
was just no not captain blue falcon i
wasn't
really a scooby-doo person i mean i
watched it when it was on when i was a
kid but really it wasn't the thing i was
like i
need to watch this i was more of a ninja
turtles kid myself who became more of a
ninja turtles man point is blue falcon
i believe his name is a blue falcon
comes on the scene and teams up and
i know that that's happened in the
cartoons like he had his own cartoon
and that crossed over with scooby-doo
which conceptually makes it an
interesting crossover thing but
crossover episodes like that and shows
never
felt like the meat of what the show
really was it was like this special
extra thing so they took the concept of
special extra thing and made it a movie
which doesn't really feel like a
scooby-doo movie because it's a
superhero movie now
with scooby-doo characters in it who
actually split up in the movie
and so you don't have that scooby-doo
mystery machine
synergy with the characters then they
come in later it kind of felt a little
jumbled and cut up to me
basically villain dick dastardly has
some dastardly deed he wants to do
so scooby doo and his friends have to
undo the dastardly deed that dick
dastardly wants to do and i gotta keep
dick dastardly from decking him over
though i will say dick dastardly's
motivation by the end i was like
i can actually get behind that what can
i say i haven't felt this much for a
villain since thanos now that it is good
the movie's still
messy but you know positives positives
looking for positive i thought the voice
actors did a good job i mean mark
wahlberg plays
captain falcon i'm gonna call him that
doesn't matter mark wahlberg was good as
him for what they had the character
be anyway dick dastardly as jason isaacs
strike that
reverse it and i learned after going on
imdb no nick nolte is not scooby doo i
never realized before this how much
nick nolte sounds like scooby doo did
you say ikea nope
i said falcon terry just like you for
the whole movie i swore this was nick
nolte a scooby-doo
not it's legendary voice actor frank
welker is he doing a nick nulty
impersonation
nope i said falcon terry just like you
maybe but this movie wasn't as fun as
the scooby-doo movie could have been you
know it didn't have any of that mystery
that intrigue it was just like someone
was like
we want to make a scooby-doo movie um oh
well superheroes are huge
let's put can we put a super oh wow he's
teamed up with a superhero before great
we're making a superhero scooby-doo
movie you may feel like you're
capitalizing on a market that's
huge because the mcu is huge not that
this has mcu characters in i'm just
saying biggest franchise on earth
for movies you get it but really what
you're doing is you're taking what could
have stood out as a mystery cartoon
movie for kids and you're putting it in
a pot where it's just gonna get lost
because it just doesn't hold up with the
rest of what we have
for superhero [ __ ] it just feels like a
generic ass superhero movie with
scooby-doo characters in it it's just
really forgettable all right glad this
review is over i'm gonna go back to
talking about things i wanna talk about
here oh i gotta write it up right
scoob i'm not gonna remember it in
t-minus one day zoe's like
already forgot all right so scoob have
you seen it what did you think about is
20 bucks to watch on amazon it's just
that's way too expensive or what was
your favorite cartoon when you were a
kid whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more